this is absolutely
humiliating video of former fox news
host bill o'reilly
this is um you know i've said before
that there's really no trend
where i've met left-wing media people
and right-wing media people and there's
no hard and fast rule about oh the
lefties are nice and the righties aren't
in fact my experience has been the exact
opposite
some of the most uh vile
mean rude people i've met in this
business
are prominent left-wing hosts i'm not
going to name them
um
i think the one i've named is ed schultz
he he you know he has passed away and at
this point it's sort of irrelevant but
not a nice guy one of the worst people
that i've ever met everybody else is
still alive
most of the right wingers have been
super nice i mean i don't like his
politics but mike huckabee
sean hannity i could go
these they're they're nice people when
you meet them in person at conferences
they'll stand around and chat and talk
shop and all this different stuff okay
but there's there's nice and rude people
on both sides bill o'reilly has a
reputation for being absolutely vile and
disgusting i've never met the guy
we now have a viral video of bill
o'reilly at a jetblue terminal at jfk
airport bill o'reilly was trying to get
to turks and caicos for his vacation and
the flight was late
the flight was late
and bill o'reilly absolutely loses it
and starts threatening a jetblue gate
agent who has no say whatsoever
about when flights come and go
with his job starts threatening you're
going to lose your job here is bill
o'reilly people who are watching might
notice bill o'reilly is looking
extremely gaunt uh i i knew he was tall
he looks
so skinny that it almost looks unhealthy
that's an aside and here he is
threatening the jetblue worker with his
job all captured on camera
and by the way can i just say
this was when the mask requirement was
still in place at airports
why does he have to pull the mask down
to talk i just i don't understand when
people do this but okay that's not for
me to understand
[Music]
wants
so yeah here bill bill o'reilly's asking
for the manager
he's three hours late now
what are you gonna do it's three hours
late the gate agent doesn't control that
you're gonna find out
you're gonna find out then he does the
thing where he looks really closely at
the guy's name tag
now bill o'reilly who's much taller than
the employee starts leaning in
intimidating this is the most
humiliating
behavior threatening with violence the
employee now says
we'll see
and off goes bill o'reilly lumbering
away um you know one other thing i i am
nowhere near as well known as uh as bill
o'reilly
but
the number of people that come up to me
in public and say hello has made me
realize i always need to be on my best
behavior i can't be on a phone yelling
at anybody if i'm at the airport i'm
going to be extremely polite if i'm
talking to my girlfriend or whatever i'm
going to make sure that everything
always looks as if everything is going
swimmingly and beautifully no matter
what is going on
uh because this is exactly what i want
to avoid and the the the yelling at
employees and threatening their jobs
particularly when don't we all know how
uh aviation works at this point in time
i once had a situation where i had a
flight delayed seven hours out of a very
small airport where there was there was
that's the one flight and it was delayed
because of weather i was miserable but
what i'm gonna do this the person at the
airport doesn't handle the flight coming
and going and it's just an absolutely
humiliating situation to be caught in
and it is not a surprise sometimes
rumors are true sometimes rumors are not
true bill o'reilly widely known as a
prick for lack of a better term
and coming off exactly that way and one
of the things that for me is
particularly bothersome
is
when
individuals
that are in that are wealthier and in
privileged positions
are really talking down to service
workers i see it more often in
restaurants where sometimes i will be
with people who are not particularly
mean people
and they just don't treat service
workers well they don't treat the weight
staff well and it makes me genuinely
uncomfortable i go out of my way to try
to treat people well and bill o'reilly
clearly doing the opposite here not a
surprise coincides perfectly with what
we
thought we knew about bill o'reilly
we'll have the clip on our instagram at
david pakman show if you've just been
listening today we'll take a quick break
and be right back
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below